[Música]
y zach hernández quien fue reconocido en
el 2018 como el mejor bailarín del mundo
novela con publicó hace casi dos años en
un año normal habría tenido más de 100
funciones en todo el mundo pero la
pandemia lo obligó a saltar a la
incertidumbre
y se refiere sus extenuantes ensayos
antes de una función que regresaron con
una prenda doble
creo que es lo que nos está costando
trabajo ahora
a sentirnos cómodos otra vez en el
escenario así como las artes y todo en
el país el ballet se ha transformado por
la pandemia una de las secuelas más
grandes de los encierros ha sido la
física me volví a doler el cuerpo como
hace años donde dolía porque yo llevaba
en los últimos cinco años bailando casi
más de 100 funciones al año entonces mi
físico estaba entrenado de una manera
muy especial el regreso al escenario
para la estrella del english national
ballet será con apenas 600 espectadores
en vez de miles con una actuación de
life and faith de vasili grossman es
sobre la segunda guerra mundial y lo que
trataba de capturar el coreógrafo es la
esencia de libros que es al final
en los actos de amabilidad que pueden
suceder en los momentos más oscuros de
la humanidad y dar un poco de esperanza
también al futuro si saque extraño su
público otro encuentro pendiente es en
méxico creo que mis padres son unas
personas muy fuertes entre siempre
pienso en ellos y en el tiempo que
estamos perdiendo juntos al final de
cuentas es eso que normalmente tengo la
posibilidad de ir a méxico con el
regreso del barrio de londres vuelve la
magia del arte que tanto hace falta